hello everyone with you grandmaster danil
naroditsky today we are participating streamer
team date i.e.
streamer arena i participate for the team of
sergey yurievich shilov cross sound for
me this is the most part we will
try so the arena started ten
minutes ago started recording a bit
late just because i have  there were
problems with the technology but 1:50 left in the
yard is not so trying to do what we can
so I have 14 seconds in this game
because I'm berserk well, that is, the
time control is three minutes but you can start you can
press the button and start the game from a minute
30 seconds and  then if you win this game
, you gain an extra point
for the team and for yourself, so I will be a
lot of berserk, especially when I
play with people whose rating is much
lower than mine, as you can see this opponent is
1200, so
you need to win, but I already have 13 left,
I tried to fix it for a long time  camera but
finally the same in my opinion everything works so
I hope you enjoy this video
I will naturally
comment on all the games I will play to
explain the moves, well, as far as possible,
when such a chain is obtained, but of
course it is very difficult to do this, as we
see the opponent thinks for a long time, he has 10
seconds, he clearly cannot play quickly,
so he has been like this for six seconds  obviously up to
40 a little bit of time and 1 we already have the first
victory on the first desk, I lost simply
because I was absolutely not
focused, well, we revealed the first
game and so the second game is again
berserk and microphone in 3 on the first move
so we play  ernesto the Indian attack I think
although anything can let's
take into account all four according to the classics we play like this 4
yes there is such an option c 6 we
develop
just put 2 in Winston kite 6 we play
we will try to exchange this word of our
family 5 5 epic star Indian position
although the price line is not clear why  so
let's win the knight on b6 so let's win be
too lazy to play very quickly understand the truth
why but it absolutely doesn't sway me
it's absolutely  oh no worries so now we
’re still invading of course had to use
7 take control let’s a4 a5 under to
secure this bishop
but he’s just paralyzed almost
wanted to end spy unpleasant another
country words just move away what terrible
6 strange it’s not clear why someone g80 down
stands as if in place we  further
advance the pawns in the foreground give
already 3 4 try h5 he barely
prepares b5 but our heart 3 is
farther from the scary one so we look
than to come up with f6 here
give h4 while we strengthen the position of haste there is no
line c we have full
control  some cop p5 he
doesn’t offer anything so I naturally
refuse the differences so he calls this
pawn well here just in my end
comrade we invade the rook on so8 then
some cop well firstly we produce those
eight let’s move back carefully mode
let’s go to c4  don't miss my pawn and you can
write just get along sims play
trade all the heavy pieces and then the
pawn just goes through with  it’s that these
owners are the 7th, I’ll return the combo 6 to
volume 9 7 by the way, I
’m left with extra quality a bunch of
such groans 8 just 6 we play well, of
course, it’s different colors 0 until the rush
just can’t stop it, I can’t,
so yes, they brought this game so normally
the king of us is
completely safe at pier 7
I’m queens and I think that he will give up soon he
still became bribes we take away we take
here-here-here and Matilda Ivanovna in
one way we move on or two
games won so the reports we clock do not
show the camera a little bit  so I don’t
understand this is a berserk, but they are, but when the
berserk is all on camera, you can do it like this, it
doesn’t make the end yes, but not there everything was by the
way normal time everything shows yes,
simply because at the beginning of the day
it’s okay they took t4 we play the
first gambit especially 4 pretty  unusual
if I'm not mistaken raki raki ruim here
you need to get of course e4 can
push the
center to take then e5 let's open the diagonal of the
bishop put the battery here  build
it absolutely does not bother me let it
take the fingers later 3 play take out he
will be forced to play 6 also further
weaken on the kingside
but f6 also quite the same quite of course
enter we will take away and invade with the queen our 5
threatens the landscape so he is obliged to play from 5
to the knight f3 game  attacking the pawn d5
we play from the edge to us from in my opinion he is
obliged to play queens 8 then we take it
on foot already 5 well there of course it’s just a
completely hopeless position until
ddd is a serious trouble for black it’s more pleasant
that
I found a bishop 8 and this one this one  I
did not take into account on the other hand took away took away
hoard and 4 .
and immediately on the right, by the way, he
played very well, yes, I was mistaken, but you were grossly
mistaken, I didn’t notice yes, the connection will come
3, he already completely called
6, come on now, z4 gt3, by the way
, the ball 2000 plays very strongly, it just
replays me so even that  it’s
even impossible that it’s possible here at all somehow
they don’t know here and 4 is just better with him
although he has three words at least some kind of
activity queen he plays here out of sums of 5
that we didn’t notice five of them did
n’t notice come here what  on
[music]
24 somehow to be two of him without knowing yes I was
wise from 70 for another 36 seconds while by the way
peeping insanely just
defending himself
[music]
just plays naturally quite simply
no but by the way there so let's play on 4
heat even it stops  so
a threatens checkmate in 1 move yawns about and yawned
checkmate is simple just a magician just man
unimat but everything benefited a lot in and yawned
yes and so played the game at night does not
give up while it was like nagma does not
give up to me 22 seconds in time  no time is
more than enough even with five
seconds from the games you can
play well, yes, it has already passed, let's go
Mr. Omer Haidar damn it, yes, I unsuccessfully
broke through that game, but in the end we
won so 1700, well, let's berserk them
and 4 we play so immediately on the attack,
well  let's play this line again c3
favorite nov hs moon 4 there is such
a line b5 you batteries before here with black
wash the car but inaccuracy just because
he took the center with pawns so with b6
if I remember correctly the rush sacrifices the
knight c3 until the theory will feed and 4 cloth 5
he is obliged to take on f3 I take away the tricks
there it’s just
such a development yes now it just hits
ana diaz
and by the way there is another variation of a corr
5 minutes before 2
took the words I give a fork if I
remember correctly White is doing well there
but by the way for a long time it’s just not  scientists
extra quality the knight crawls out through big ones
yes here it’s just in my opinion if I’m
playing exactly the position should be
hopeless in principle, let’s own c 1 by a tricky
move and mm from the bishop again checkmate  strongly
Ivanovo
I played this game quite successfully
so let's see who is ahead of us let's
once again pressure km2 200 still not a
weak chess player but still a minute and a
half before it's not minutes it's not 30
seconds so it's still time to
think  what is it, well, the London
system so we play this variation on a slope
with this, which we also don’t really
like 5 this is all theory up to here and 8 8 5 up to the 5th
floor in my opinion for black is good again 4
well, such a very sharp struggle
here as a result,
you know what  something, let's maybe
just take away take the rook and let's
cs6 we on the other side let's just
take you and then like f3 we will grunt words for a
year as many as three typical those of such positions and
he doesn't even take it but I took it then by the
way it just doesn't react here
okay  tifosi carried away 4 defending this pawn we
don’t give the pawn to the un 100 minutes from I didn’t
notice
to eat it’s just that they raise it from
such a raise I’m just shocked by these
people and I have to completely play 6
moreover  plays faster than me what is the most
amazing thing here but took away something like a war
yawned so you can’t just play
fast and yawn the most important thing is that he yawns
plays very fast so we win another one quickly
so the international master once
again with a five again we make a berserk
just because we have to  we will try to win a lot of
games for sergey yurievich,
gentlemen, so we play the
option by linking you, but I also participate in
blitz, by the way, this option
is not at all simple, just under, but because
having established itself, it’s worth giving kebab
4th layer, 5, well, yes, already white
will just get such a pawn  on d4 all the
controllers but should play fast on
c5 orient mukunda 5 extreme but
it will come it doesn’t scare us we
will stand our knight on e5 we will stand the words
through all 2 we will activate but it is
so weakened now now f4 savchenko’s
fastenings are grumpy not f4 still true
went to these owns a squirrel we yawn a fork we
don't yawn
so an elephant until 6 okay let's just
let's like this hip hip hip n
we’ll play it scrapped up to 2
legs, an ideological move, so now let’s even
strengthen it, but you don’t need to look for nyash, but
on the other hand, you just want to
put an elephant on this diagonal,
this tactic is formed with the move t5,
I decided to take it so famous, but the quality
is marked in short  damn, even
so, let's sum it up, he's paralyzed about the transfer,
but they also just sat there, the
atom children 4p climbed the courts and 4 and
win the queen finally 4 though
initially the figurant loses like this, by the
way, he has four of the counterplay a4, he
needs to sacrifice the cutter, he doesn't do that
but 4 they have 4 here it is forced in the club
to 30 to 100 with more pieces
they took away at school and by the way the rook is not the
best pawn to scorch 2 was littered with
d4
so what am I carrying you just need to
play this pawn
you are completely crazy c5 they took away  by the way, the
rook is a little bit trapped on the other
side, he can’t attack her three
four by four they took two passers from
us here
servants 103 and so let’s plan here  just
forward again and sabitov 5 ax of the season the
crisis must be shown to break through this
technique is not the end yet so they took it
there is 6 it’s not the end yet put it on for an
hour but I saw this I think I
’m taking away and the king f1
I don’t see how he further strengthens the position
but  we will somehow unleash the suslonger 6 video
80 for example, I’m
like this, something like this, yes, I also inaccurately,
I spent this stage, of course, but still it
should be enough to win, so
also the jackdaw plays andrey zhukov sergey
these are strong people of games from us tournament so
elephant I'm six let's somehow
connect the slope like this and by the way sony 4 yes
I forgot owning 8 threatens f8 pers rook
everything I give byd f3 like this and
now such a trick is connected to the court
he took away and I was back to eat everything
tying the bishop now 2 2 extra bishops we
have surrender lord lord with 69 with 2
extra words i still succeed
i still get the game to enter here
without
ceremony dream bishop g4 let's
win this game quickly again  we don’t take it here for
Vasya, but the dude parasite here doesn’t give up yet, but
finally gave up,
we’ll win another 5 on the desk.
for a team of two calks, we have 397
berserk aim managed to berserk at 2399
opponent, but still give them berserk
quickly nc3 big of course move left
options and there is to get an advantage
counter they just but that the capture of the
c6 knight is we will try to punish
what he is  makes these moves quickly in the center
in the center up to 6.5 we play just strictly according to the
classics strictly in the center
here somehow I’ll finish 6 will play but I
don’t like it and people who then by the
way pawn legs 4 yawn well, well, I
’m making a
pawn on d4 yawned  well, somehow I
’ll finish 5 saying but we need to talk because I don’t know
zombie c2 just takes another one to the
unscrupulous one we’ve been developing for a long time playing for
development what to do now on a horse 6 it’s
just that it’s developing further now I’ve been
very clever to prove it I could
n’t and moreover  left without two jackets
compensation is very doubtful but
let's try let's be shocked by the kicker of the
elephant in the fight he plays rather
slowly so let's try to throw them into
time trouble  3 and 4 finks type of bishop well
but byd f3 doesn’t move at the exit doesn’t move
first 2
well, yes, the position hardly plays very
strong for me, leads the game,
okay, with big radiations, one
further draws out that game, he
thinks about the moves for quite a long time, therefore,
but how  on each move for five seconds
3 4 5 kun move isn’t it strange
well okay then continue to play these four
just every move we take off for 3
seconds this is a little bit
strange to me it just scares me okay up to 4
s really
no one  not 56 they will connect no this is
this this this person this person
I think that he cheats quite
possibly you 2 see he spends
literally from 3 to 5 seconds for each move for each
without exception three four five six
seven
seconds again so but we  hold on like that here
you have to somehow hold on so that he overstayed time once
and yawns a horse you can 4 dead 2 well,
how is it one hundred percent 4 the presence of
light is just a huge problem still in the
form now I don’t and still
do  we can take it, but it’s under and in 30
seconds already to give quickly and locked up
it’s harmful to see how a person plays well, yes,
you move the cross beech
ahead by about 50 points, you need to
win further, I immediately understood after the move
six people are retired very strange,
let’s go on without berserk million 5,500
opponent is very strong, let’s play
calm classics 2,500
we are berserker  im dont know who lm is
on from Russia, someone lance is
obviously strong near the quarrels,
so we play clearly here
[music] then
we bring it out, let's
sum up the volume on the water now, we are forming
alexander yudin
yes, I don’t like a lot of alexander
gel mannanov’s part, it’s just nice to watch him, let’s put it together
you, well,
ours from my track
dresses at 8 that the horse has 4k money to
go nowhere for 6 is your dick 6
is yes so they took it owning again I
knit 6 we are taking root we are waiting by pressing the
tablet probably by the tahoe river we
took horses 8 okay so we moved away then we
insert well okay let's take it
it’s just that, of course, this position will win this
position, it’s necessary here, what a pancake with a mouse, and
now, having ended the water up to 7
, we’ll quickly sum it up, yes, it won’t be easy to
win here, but it’s necessary so let’s not
know how to play correctly enter the king
will discuss so that later the bundle of the bundle would not
be there I’m in what  -I want to
keep the moment, so we centralize on one bishop,
now we also introduce the knight into the
game, discard the bishops 4, we want
to keep one  if it’s like this somehow
to arrange the pieces, then you’ll hold 6 for
now everything has taken his grandfather 7 but
here, of course, there should already be a rather
hopeless position simply from if from 5
seconds to 6 it goes like this and now we
can just h4 whisper a pawn
tossing ships on  stealing 85 and it threatens to
have knights for everyone with all this so
let's go further h5
back here another pawn by 7 sags well
yes here is a question of technique or caution
but which I did not show I blundered and
although there is like this and the rook beta 7 she
wins and  4 we give a fork,
but I'm lucky here, I need
to play more carefully, more carefully a6 threatens la keep
checkmated on a horse 645 we play and another 6 mm from everything
you can just give up checkmate go on
quickly win one more game again
with air again percy rkka im one more
long London system
so once again so we play so we already had
it with another opponent ball they with
him 45 of 3d free hot strong in three hot
strong although weakness is created
and hold 4 here is a very sharp position
you need to play quickly, calmly, carefully, and
exactly the most important thing is 4,
I’m not familiar with this move, let’s try 4
counter-strike, his king is very weakened,
so we throw the game out as quickly as possible
and snowstorm 1, by the way, our knight d4 in
my move is a strong comic 3 threatens  you
bad luck 4 take a pawn in the gap or
not but bits 4 king h1 of took
away took away .  five elephants 2 how let's
try and also fer for 6 yes there is
very, very attack
md5 now and then then I don’t understand what is the idea
if I’m cs6 game
if c6 graph than dear friends of course
yes not oak we have a little well done just a
huge ma  -well done Snoop well done like a pickle
here it is in the swing here we throw it in the swing
darling you when you nyushka
so they took the horse the end just the cognac
we take the horse and there it is matte so
let's go on one more game we
win if we still carry the
team of the chair forward and  let's share a circa with them
quickly for 5 my favorite
variation is bishop to 2 what kind of move here is it
just an extra pawn now we will have
because the brothers will succeed on the
other side so c5
we are just an extra pawn already almost a
hopeless position right from the opening where
a  took egypt why did i put it on
but he yawns one more place he yawns
another wife yawned sc2 background at six
let's just walk without two to 4 is not
lost bring the elephant well here just
a matter of precautionary technique
which we will try to show again 5
bring the bishop on the air sessions defend the
pawn
take the square and 5 under control for the word 4
first b6 naturally exchange of queens to my
advantage to my advantage
yes syngi 4 just the end almost
so although 60 from a prophylactic point of
view on  just in case, we’re just
defending the pawn, so it suits me like this for now
, yes, it’s too early to celebrate
here, it’s absolutely not the end far,
here we still need a technician to lead to a mini
fortress formed like this, let’s
try to exchange all heavy pieces, we’ll exchange
everything and take control of the lines
it’s canceled just
that they exchanged the knight further, well, with two
forest pawns, I’ll manage to win, well,
let’s somehow go there, I just don’t know
there and we’ll make 2 passed pawns for our pawn,
she just transfers the end
just 44 here-here-here they took it and surrendered
so okay
let's win another jigalko andreev the pressure by whom, let's not go berserk
fell
c3 bishop c4 so I am not familiar with this
new tech 3
that it is up to 7 yes probably there is such an
option so here probably 5 months before 2
you played the jab system somehow
unsuccessfully I broke up with me yes somehow
stretched me here a little position
okay  6 5 bending got caught somehow
doesn’t go at all saved me 6 okay so
let’s defend somehow antrag
him from this room 4th as well they took and
queens 2
it’s probably the face yes by the way there are 5
cm plays on c5 will have to be taken to
something doesn’t play well with the village, it’s strange
if I’ve always been like this and now there wasn’t
a move like this c5 yes here what is there and we
have already succeeded although the other side
still now everything is just bursting at
all the seams unfortunately it’s just bursting at all the
seams 6234  us this is also nikolay
what are these h4 but damn are they in business or just
can’t he always oh according to her yoga on the
grain again
then the idea of \u200b\u200bthe wall but any side there is th
s one here it’s not the end on foot on we
move although he has a field and 4 for
horse but don't know boims  I am we or not
six, let's already 5, probably,
or while we wait, I don't know, let's, for the time being,
prophylactically collect how 2 and on
horseback 4 UAH z5 so that it is not a move, they drive
5 and then for a moment she has 5 before I
like the positions here I
Andrey Zhigalko's jackdaw has been around for a long time already Andrey
Zhigalko I haven't fully played about availability. Sergey
could not play today,
so my
brother joined him, he also makes a lot of
noise and puts what it does to the lines, no, it
gives first b5,
so that is, I didn't understand, so here it is necessary for
sure  find here I already feel
some kind of tactics so here I am again and
well there percy 4 what to do what
to do maybe the end of 5
yes I don’t feel like it either but we play okay
there is no time on the disk this is a draw some kind of
draw in my opinion  6 maybe it is also
not clear why on which side where is
this
and now tomorrow that the queens 8 probably a
draw on
the strait 8052 an interesting idea f5 a
strong idea in 5 we move them 5-6 threatens
and the rook h8 from I don’t see the defense gentlemen I
don’t see the defense  on  in my opinion, he yawned in
my opinion actively, in my opinion, we will now
take out the zhigalko, and if the king f8 is even there we push the
check into it there isn’t in it itself
there is in my gentlemen there I think I
see anri zhigalko and also sergey is also
playing pancake and sergey andrey they both
play  here and check dick to
them and just put 8 we go in f6 checkmate the
most important game was knocked out and from such a
position there was just a box there was the
most important game so once again a berserk they had a
chance to win a couple more games
as a variation of shibalo plays also
didn’t quite understand and we will play one of these
just namaz and at 56 he wants he wants to be
unpleasant again we will play again like
this keep one which 4 I think
let's just first collect the same 4
combat Xia 2 and the crowns fell below such a pancake
finally 5 earthly then we take from what the
foundation happened
here here  it must be already
hopeless so much of this figure has been
collected if the rook understand this 400 here
we are still invading here, gentlemen,
since now we continue to find exactly
very  play so what so so so
so so gentlemen one more
win won two more 408 5 berserkers once again
we need to win all the games to close
b3 we will also play this variation very much I
love this one I love all three by the way the
variation is often played by mikhail antipov or
antifa  I don’t know I refuse to pronounce
probably types let’s now here and
then quickly focus on the length of castling
at home and already 4
f4 maybe at least f4 quickly
ending 8 this is it yes of course so without
development plays here for 4 naturally
sacrifices we prepare the sacrifice of the knight d5 and the cepslin
then  let's dress it up, of course, it's very
dangerous, but if I took it, and if like
this and like this and then also like this, as he
puts on, well, conditionally 6 it seems 4 you can
just play the end of a6 but we took it
back we are 2 leading the elephant in the
contour of the game there  there was no e5 and if they
took it like that or it’s already taken too much here by
Zeus,
but in my opinion it’s good, I took it and on slope
71 we drop it here, in my opinion, it’s just the
end you can study it can’t
under  he can’t fix his position, I
just took it without 4 pawns there still without an
exchange o I think she’s food and her stomach is full to
yawn from the move tass so let’s then c4
okay not yet still need to correct
some careful a and took the heart 7 and
why am I here  I went to these
ceremonies here to screw up the noise
on the other side here, in my opinion, even with
all this, ersatz 3,
pushing the air for 8, threatens to checkmate the king,
it’s true,
yes, somehow it doesn’t work, of course,
you can find a blow there, even queens can be changed  there are 4 of them there, a million,
I’ll just have to find the most accurate one, oh,
what a beautiful blow, don’t sleep on this,
let’s rook davos, what income and
taking mine 8 messina, like this,
we play gentlemen, we roll, we roll out, we
roll out, we
surrendered again, we won so 2,400 one more
berserkers one more time and then
berserk something everyone plays these leftist
systems I don’t know what kind of strange system
but I’m already better Kelly 19 some kind of
incomprehensible to passively plays
very well  even passively but here of course it
’s not so easy to take advantage of the position is
not strong enough such 4 and if he
took the paint what so your
meticulousness is a good idea but it won’t work
they took the aikan si4 here well why am I
yawning here all the time I have grain already three
times in a season already which  in it,
in fact, she didn’t notice we have another
shooter this idea at the end 4 unpleasant
some moment he leads let’s just
then and 4 how is it now here he gave me the truth
then polyphony
why and also all the growths I don’t know the law
plays but I have 51 points  60 so where d1
really yes here it’s not easy to overcome this
i.e. he seems to be playing very
passively but carefully so if 4 we
still push the oil 1 m d 1 then he
took me back here to the end just here
he never even Comic Con  will be able to
activate therefore here just everything
exactly at 4 still paralyze everything else
again yes here the question of technology is quite
simple
we are
waiting for the next batch of vache with our
strong ones and not the collection of the lower seville I know
who it is let's see who it is the day and the collection of
sleep I'm tired of course winning the decline of the
set since Mr.
important to those courts by the way 6
became 3 still bent a little beckoned
okay
sudan and I don’t know how much to darn him here we
naturally don’t berserk them oh damn back
such a strong ax in blitz for some reason
you, according to the classics, are
nothing
special in blitz  I win all the time in
some magical way, they
just took it back from here, and if we return it
back from here, it should have been even without the pace,
they are already better, it’s just incomprehensible how he
does it and at such a speed, it’s generally
damn tin just tin, so I know what
’s going on here who is better
absolutely incomprehensible by the way  it still sags
in the center for somehow reluctance to take it there,
let's do it mt-3 on the right of income
that they themselves did not notice when they took the
coin photo of a wrong move  no, I just
take it back to f3, in my opinion
, here too, then I collected on c3, looking for
we will get it, I probably still have the
initiative, even I will win so many
games after all, and also max
for a hand 55 points, I have 65 main  end
4 played so leaving what kind of garbage is this
and if we play him like this and if we play him like
that what will Mr.
Baron
Aslan do now 22 then they yawned they
still didn’t find it there either so for we sold with a
horse
rc2
forced like a  if we
throw the elephant in here we drop the elephant on the
heart 1 room 2 queens would just
catch my
version of 2 some kind of form there is a beetle
not 5 for example as example 1 they
collected it calmly just
somehow again for example an important game of
course a grandmaster yes it is necessary with him  to
finish him off here somehow firs 6
sorted out step 3 maybe here 301
then they took away the complete nonsense they didn’t
give up so for an important perfumer or from a
profit
they won all one important party from a profit
Zhigalko serg  she
needs to win this game so let's
play better what we're playing here
let's play 6 for 5
we'll play this variation of the left I know it pretty
well I think so now
you have to play big here quickly and
sacrifice a second pawn if
nova 6 is able
to develop quickly  it’s necessary
and now, in my opinion, we’re just swarming the rivers,
sacrificing a stape from pipe 1 and maybe t 5 to
5 5 end 64 here here here here or up to
6 I do
n’t remember which of these moves is being made,
let’s try up to 5 except
find and try such a move for 2
grandmaster in a row, and both are looking for
black, we gave them e5, now I think
maybe you’re not sure here, to be honest,
let’s try,
but if he took the end of 6 thousand, by the way, he
took it and somehow it’s necessary, but he took the icon b3,
in my opinion, the grandfathers alone in law jammed even more
2 for a long time we have been playing activity
somehow okay, and then you can still
transfer the knight to be, if possible, own
one, by the way, there is still nothing special about
these courts on horses for activity, we play the
role of e3, yes, I saw  such a move dc1 to you
this is a draw we
repeat the fact I know that there is a way to win with
black and white you can win
that now again something queens 88 is
better than g3 so now 5 maybe I
don’t know what to say what to do maybe it’s
just it’s still similar to me  the same 5
given limitation we play the court the
problem is something and blundered this I
blundered terribly yes this move is a very unpleasant
pawn aiming for a pawn and if here the check
threatens shorter than 8 firstly he is obliged to give a
check to the icon b5 another idea by the way interesting I
don’t know  4 yes, just the end later 4
let's look out for me, why am I doing it
now it just comes to f4 I don’t know yet by the
way there 12
reeling with online opportunities but grandfather
512 all the same, he also
wants to take something here in height if so and at 6
what  I don’t have a trap to find, in principle
, I have no way out 6
they have 4 still owning 2, so
yes, yes, I played very well on that game, you need
to take your hat off here, it’s just the end, well,
even a bichon, at least one, for example, how
anything happens
everyone sees everything  he sees mister Zhigalko t5
he took the check or not they took it oh
damn it so he found iPhones raised
oh damn the mouse to her
if such protection
where he dropped the mouse on everyone is okay
anyway hopeless position although there
probably we will cut down the flags well okay in
short anything can happen
[music]
let's go on berserk they are not at all
good we tried it tried after all
h6 with this move I don’t know how you
became in this we didn’t hurt at all just the
abyss should call oh damn that
we are such an elephant I 3 yawned  my husband is already completely
stupid, just eat lucky here, but we
play very weakly, we invade
here
, blow into the NHL, where it’s dark, hopeless
bottoms on black, so
ahead now in team relations, I’m
not sure, I hope that we, that is, cross
beech, oh,
well, what is so careless as  - then I
began to play, okay, we’ll win the desk, but it
still doesn’t give up, doesn’t give up, mister, the
end of the tomato is set, then we
move on, we move on, you played on
we are ahead, but somewhere on 50 points  so we
have to continue to win to tass
berserker
and he is also a berserker well, thanks 6
top up the left option I don’t know
what kind of garbage it is, I don’t know without two of
course just out of two without two notes
some kind of compensation, but there is of
course
so  I don’t know they took it again they took
it, maybe we’re drawing the bishop on my graph,
which does not inspire confidence to continue
to deal with 3, of course, it was completely
unsuccessful here that I spent the article here, but it
threatens 1 to 7,
it’s not clear how to defend against this,
he g5 raised the move glen scored that I think
that  here you can think of
nights so mom won here just
some kind of no I didn’t benefit from hq
by doing the truth it’s not clear signal to my son a
pawn and gave up there
won yes it turned out to be a difficult opponent
but there let’s go on quickly berserk
gaming let me period sex code god of
sex
funny  here sacrifice a pawn it must be a
mistake on how to take advantage of not sure the
court maybe here
maybe something so really wants this pawn
n  to donate he offers nothing I
refused the center this is a sign to me of a good trial
so he and he is instantly taken away by
an amazing
person also 5 10 stage this
this we do not believe absolutely take
and take just
let's interface okay assure in
my opinion here you have returned must be
sure  look at this attack, well,
through the seed exchanges where there is no this here
I forgot about it forgot I don’t know what’s
going on here to be honest and incomprehensible I
’m learning and in general it’s happening
should be won from me if he
took it I probably took it there should be a
mate no share it  just hanging in the
air still hanging in the air rook bt-7 so we
think we think we think let’s
even take your fire even 6 we’ll take our topic it dates oh
damn forgot about it I took it all alone
in my opinion here it still turns out
that won owns there is in the word 27 thousand
m yes  I’ll just substitute the end, by the
way, a beautiful school desk and a checkmate should be king
8 and calculated up to 8, the end
once again offers again, but it will probably be
side  it’s just that we’ve given up here we’ve won
an important game now we’ve burned all the important games
how we’re getting
closer to getting a lighter we need to continue to
win again peach they need to
now it will be all the berserkers
to win pretty quickly drags oh queens 3 well,
pepper with pepper and also, of course, we play
and drag honestly  the team just
simply drag the lighter will also help the
berserkers so that everyone on the desk will
win a lot
here from the ideas of b5 in the form of low-fat victims,
let's go against and a bit already 42 now on the
5th line we will open here b3 so here's how here
and if we took a day somehow
win back a pawn  square e5 acquiring
30 I don't know yes difficult opponent
got
here moder malatesta today before 5 white
first money 5 bishop g4 so I think
they took well get black of course only
probably all the same
but little time remains strong very
opponent very strong opponent this
august 1962  still playing fast how
fast I want to hope everyone wins a pawn
on and 4 days you have seven until s  I don’t know
what we’re going to do with this pawn, but he
throws it out, I can just call the pawn
so it’s already something it’s something so here
then a4 we weaken it already takes
here I don’t know about it blundered back the pawn right away
and instantly I noticed it’s
amazing to enter here yes  this I will return
over pretty simply without no frills
from apple and no frills and also 5
some move unpleasant 4 not but it’s
just a machine some kind of just a machine the
feel is implemented completely here the
victims are completely paralyzed I don’t know how
this game to win just a person sees everything
I haven’t seen such a thing for a long time 2 469 h5
just a car I just don’t know 4 tons or
not but most likely that I didn’t have it
all the same somehow better but on the other hand
he suddenly started playing so much he ate
even no just burned the creep wins
constantly just another kalkan
also a car of course
[music]
and we have to play like that oh damn no he is
one hundred percent 4 you are at home i.e. he
noticed this idea instantly yes i
think 4 he is quite possibly lagm at the end
an maxim 40
corner of us further plays until the
last
part of the beatriz note 3
horse 6 is completely bad, then we come here on one we need to
win fast food a little
Denis food record of the jig is already a jackdaw for me to
just catch up and I’m chasing, although now we
may be able to win a couple of parties in a row
with 4 to play something DSLR
understandably win does not win Zhigalko
win 66 well, a typical idea yes to you and
here I already have dominance f5 on
also unpleasant for a move summing up the volume
hitherto very some other one was
captured just all are so strong I still have
also 5-6 a lot now it’s gone to me
if some tilt still 56 finds no
still haven’t found yet what to do it’s
not clear absolutely what to do I took
it all right at home and back to r2
maybe then blown away how
much
[music]
but slowly but slowly jigalko
maybe he will lose, yes, a very strong person,
that Maxim cheese is already five, such a
typical idea, he collected and took
an intermediate move, taking the exchange from
hopelessly it needs to be what to do
why this one I made the courts won everything
back I paused the berserker in let's
go on to the jigalko lost and greatness I
already gave to such an important result
let's try this idea
I don't remember here how to play number six
[applause]
Zhenya  they use energy with mongrels, so on
f3 it was impossible to have a pawn from there, it’s
just possible, so don’t you
think I’m black all the time
[applause]
another 10 for strong ones so here with an idea not
54 more than 6 peacefully I don’t really understand why
this is all  let's start though 6
window we make 3
here at the beginning grandfathers 16 collects not
just a person to win not
just a riveter we find a supercreep from his
type of bergamo to a player not 5 in the Berlin
style 5 of course there is such a typical
move but I don’t really want to give that
we repeat I succumb 1az  who ruled basically
those six and here we connect what to do my
terrible want you admitted a pancake
how they took away he also put a horse on the i46
and how to defend him here he took from  I
took
what he has now done to you up to 2 kuni
5 to 2 in my opinion won
19 seconds of the finger 2
collected everything
there is the most important game we are winning we are
ahead now we need to berserk nuta
win another couple of games also super-set
him okay to hell with him berserk berserk
let's play in style  peppers to them are a whole series of 35
passages we are not afraid let's a4 and then
in some cop f4 here is a syringe
[music]
so if I took it probably as an elephant all the
same but digging in the mink
yes yes yes yes here it’s not just that it
will continue so slowly I’m too  with
games too slow we are at 5 5 there is a
move well and naturally I want to
donate 4 so I don’t know e52 maybe
she c5 what to do with her on the tricky
spoons to soak and 54 removed didn’t understand
absolutely didn’t understand took but if he
took even the king up to 2 of  2
or pipes 1 these are the best king 2 so that
there are no problems later I don’t absolutely believe
in this but
caution is necessary and the
pawn takes the pawn what am I doing
it can I underestimated for with black compensation of
course I greatly underestimated before
very simple end
here
journey 4 important move they there dress
takes mac g4 higher until the time I do
n’t have no need to go berserk don’t need
it that things threaten rooks one by the way but
[music]
also 4 and if c4 was taken in my opinion
mating here here  here
we take another one here yes we wash and eat but you own it
out of the mud, that is, a million different
mats threaten yes and if I took it I just took the
end of the most important game we still wear new games
give up already surrendered there
we take out the gentleman for an hour or yes there is no step 1
and
there is a grandmaster  next game, let's
not stop the fruit of the
berserker again 2592
coarse 96 we don't know who it is f5 in general,
yes, this is it, by the way,
there is such an option, I saw it, it is advisable to
go and give it twice, you are afraid so let's
now conditional in 4 like this  now you
can’t play like that with the idea in 3 in the sense
here on those 3rd
pancake yawned but although from such a month 4
yes here I started to yawn but to her
and I touched her on this I gaped somehow
here and first again here more
powerful the most powerful players play just see
absolutely everyone plays faster than me it’s
amazing I write
tiwi strong people can’t yes again I’ll
lose here completely unsuccessfully
lately gram 3 somehow window
let’s do nothing but he
naturally refuses although he took it and
I’m sure  that everything is so simple here, it
will be so easy for him, after all, let’s go back or let’s a4
what should be given, by the way, a trap
1 5 times 6
hustle is 5 damn it so they took it in here
3 you have to play of course it was now he
can’t already cut down the flag they took by the way
just lose supports there  we
wear we did it we did it we
will win another important game for
chris book
let's berserk them forward and now
we have scored if you need to look for something to stay
eat
here how now we will continue to
bandage it let's of 3
logical move
back here we link well yes here
just  hurry of course not at all in an
unpleasant position and gave up just
give up again won the phone  esu
[music]
phone calls okay after the party,
these are faster let's dial the iPhone horse
c6 then that the call is this, I'm not familiar with this,
and I also got a position without a tempo,
it was terribly necessary to focus
better, but the bonaparte gathered here somehow more
passively, of course, the whole thing  played out
here so took it away where the noise of the horse
came here so now I’ve collected it
for us so
but it’s better at home I have a little bit in this
school all the time is not enough but we will try
we will try to try such a Berlin
one we will succeed but now by the way I
take it.  loved sitting this one
there is such a structure in berlin before
well as this better but it’s not clear how to
implement all this of course so let’s 4
maybe five maybe I really
probably didn’t need to start again like this
to play pieces a corkscrew was formed
and now you can sit like this 5  it
won't be easy here to win this game
5 I don't understand what he's letting go of
now it's impossible to take forward again in
my opinion won here if he took that 96
ends just f6 well, all the kings at
5 here it's already hopelessly squinting calls
weren't right here and there  -here always
and here let's finish
somehow
eat well so then we
wait again azarov yes ok let's not
berserk this time you spear circa
abs use 5 mouse me well damn well well
so sloppy yet very carefully
try to become one  maybe it's not so
bad as flexible development i
got here panda 3 really quite
hopeless i have it just nazarom i
really don't like to play 9 agre  ssive
very rolls out very aggressive 9
rolls out so courts so at least the knight
still has some development so that I can
get c5 later by the way if I
could put the end on f3 father again with
one so it’s bad here again
everything is not so bad but if I took it  or at the end of 6, too,
nothing more than doing there, how did he
take it, I take it on the bishop, by the way, c4 was
interesting, okay, or with a knight it was necessary
to take it, we don’t know where the sun is, 3
sense, since here what are we going to do
now, would we like it not openly not
it’s just not clear how to achieve this,
you see with the knight on q5 it’s also
unclear how to translate it,
but here it’s not an easy position, you need
to think, you need to think, and my king is
also in danger, it’s natural, it
can repeat the moves, by the way, I don’t see
these boards here clearly so
that to prepare a long castling
this sign  a superficial move of strange one of these
we will try long castling which
we don’t give a pawn on everything naturally 4 we are like
so 5 hopelessly just took and 5
of 6
I returned here and here is such a trap on
slando 4 for trematodes I took yes oh
they yawned the anchor for a third did not
yawn sergey azarov pier and rub the move
maybe he yawned a slack lamp five cows to
8 5 6 at the end of the 8th blind then before me
yes, look, gentlemen, service 5 to you,
his knight c6 passes the servants c6 king e7
there, without a check, you see it, it’s just a
beautiful game, if of course we
will get a berserker 96 now he will
catch up with me Mr.
Zhigalko how is it that Jones only
won the game  before beautifully stack 6 sacrifice a
knight a
pawn the field if we open for the king
and Azarov they
pulled out just I think
there is less they did it for the skin and you can
give up just like that they pulled it out great
and and zhigalko drank again yes
how is it with whom is he playing how is it  it's
all happening like this and the team is catching up with us
, let's start faster, how is
it that he won four games in a minute, he
absolutely didn’t understand how everything is
going on ahead, pancake, the team is
ahead, yes  let's
rise again 2 faster translate all forward
berserk them all forward
sacrifice all the victims edge instantly
what to do I have strong opponents
enough to do nothing I can't do
very strong players further I have it
worse here just with the debut this day from
pandas dinner got taken away this one  I
absolutely didn’t understand the stupid ones from everything,
so now I did something
to do poke and back only two
of sitting we
’ll fill everything aslan c5 with him she’s there
beautifully the idea is
that you take the horse and took it so but there is
n’t there  even a mat there is no [ __ ] some kind of
floor on these 5 can be the
most accurate and I know the corolla heavy king in 3d
if georgia yes immediately I end there
also
I own in mine just gave up quickly
win an important game let's go on
cross beech outstripped Zhigalko again
let's  continue to give brought out and forward
we bring in the berserk mt5 Kelly's system has an
incentive Kelly let's play three correctly
dude 3 rapists of course for the sake of
g5 causes like we blundered in this whole
the idea and gave up quickly won
there is another berserk and let's go on
gentlemen the most important game we won
there 456
so faster accounting fast play too
really it is not clear why so t6 before here
there is nothing at all and still
it looks like I obviously try to
f4 somehow  to move the game in, it is necessary to
cook 5 more points to gain the servants ahead 35 45
f3 an interesting sacrifice, but somehow I also like all
this for a dubious position,
I got 2573 very strong
opponent so they took it as if of course
you can’t give it, okay, we can also exchange Frize,
I don’t mind  and as if somehow
giving let's play like this better we took it we
didn't yawn here no we yawn
exiled we centralize four warriors d5 he
leads what am I doing that the winemaker here
[music]
unsuccessfully played that game of course
back in 4 4 sat down to give just right
on  cash tapes [ __ ] earthly [ __ ] so
this is a chance the icon gives 5 would already be 400 so
they took
him to pick it up there in general quite
hopelessly of course there just replay
our fido fido master played some kind of game, of
course, I had to win 5 points on the desk,
but I didn’t get
everything yet, what to do here slowly but
slowly the game is understandable what to do
there is a draw
why didn’t he give anything understandably
saved in some miraculous way  she just
saved a long game of the balkans something
unpleasantly the strongest player was born and then
go berserk quickly and figure it out roar
they need to win a couple of parties still
it is desirable to win everything one Londoner
so let's probably understand why
such a
Londoner is so okay courts and 4 let's
quickly try without much thought
still win three or four
games
here we play so aggressively we’ll just try to play for
us from us just like that
and also the berserk juggernaut didn’t win again
damn he’s so fast for everyone with whom
he plays jigalko some 3 300
why are we yawning just for the quality of milk
he can collect with this and the queen of the collection is
quite strange plays in a good way
strange and 4 and 6 and 2 improve
too much  m slowly, I probably even win this game,
I played very slowly
somehow it plays very strangely and does not
give up, which is the main thing,
and one more horse we have blundered the horse
oh damn it turned around
that the horse is hanging, he doesn’t take it, he
just doesn’t take it 5 give up  wife
reliably already without quality just
pulls out your pulls out pulls out and
pulls out by the way it resists quite well
and the water
should also bend 3 well, I’m completely
crazy from that place on the flag to play this
game will win no need to
come again then we’ll come oh damn well  well it
's the same I did what I did
[music]
what did I do but he
suddenly began to play so much just a monster
just a monster dachshunds it still feels so well
look just how this person plays a
masterpiece just a masterpiece
yes there is a damn fight
yes  no win it's a win it
counts as a win we did we
did it counts as a win or parts
somehow so let's go on
let's still on the desk win another one  well,
sometimes we win games, then sometimes I have
some kind of life about Evans, why the hell is he not a
berserker and something a person doesn’t cross
then and such a ketevan tale is not the road with
Turkey Turkish grandmaster so
inter-m
so a
kirovka lighter still rolls ladies
zhigalko again  can lose the knight,
we bring the principle to any move,
practically, except for the bishop c4, one more
game was taken to win f4 polina pawn
on b5 nd2 you decided to march, so by the way
, my position is quite normal if
I managed to play four more, yes, here’s
sb5  the player is a Turkish
grandmaster, then
they also own the e34 water and took the money 5 so
now do something
for 3 somehow a function 3 the truth is that the
trouble is quite a magician, after all, he took the
whole pawn to take the pawn to take to the
trouble position but the flag will leave to
chop Mitino
again  he’s making a passed pawn and
what am I doing there just the end should have
been berserk with him he has twenty-three
hundred flowers she plays like 3000
misunderstood  but how does it do it, but
okay, so the zhigalko somehow won
the position here to the wedge that the
person is not mistaken in feeling him,
just strange, very gentlemen, very
strange,
they hibernated, he, in my opinion, yawned,
gives us still life, but in the same pawn
collects my leg by percentage, this doesn’t
happen, just what kind of nonsense are
you, how did he notice all this elephant again,
no such thing doesn’t happen, this is
on him, well, in my opinion, with games up to 50
points, I come 50 points ahead of the
next one, let’s do it again
we’ll try to play one game and everything to
fix it just let’s go
sacrificing the quality
[music]
pro can also be unpleasant of course the
Zhigalko continues to win, it’s
amazing of course they won’t have time,
that is, I hope to lose
completely Turkish again.
the last two pro game ok everyone
won gentlemen
long the last 2 lost but as we
can see the cross was winning aspire
streamer tournament team tournament
so I hope I could help okay on
this and finish gentlemen
I hope you enjoyed it I
will try even more doing a broadcast
like this  you can find me on twitch and i
stream mentally in english but the russians are
also eager to everyone thank you so much for
you shooting grandmaster this is
not narodets see you soon and good luck to everyone
bye